[Musique]
on a fait le choix de descendre d'une
division l'année dernière donc la
fédérale 2 on a tendance à fêter les
défaites depuis quelques années
maintenant on arrive à fêter les
victoires
il était de se faire plaisir reprendre
renouerait un peu avec la victoire
on a eu pour objet qui vraiment de
d'essayer de refaire refédérer un groupe
voilà accueillir des débutantes les
jeunes qui arrivent de cadettes et là
cette année on en a on a eu quatre ou
cinq je crois et c'est à peu près ça
tous les ans donc ces défis qui ont déjà
de l'expérience et qui viennent
brillamment relevé le groupe ou ses fils
à vienne deux fois ou trois fois par
semaine elle s'entraîne dans le froid
dans la boue malgré les conditions
climatiques et à chaque entraînement
apprennent des coûts des impacts a subi
sa prendre des poisons dossier dont quoi
je pense qu'il faudrait c'est d'essayer
de mettre en avant tous eu ce courage
ça fait trois ans qu'ils ont fait à
poitiers j'en avais fait quand j'étais
en terminale dans mon lycée habré sur et
bien moi c'est par une amie qui était
archi baigné dans le rugby de qualité
tout petit son père était rugbyman sait
faire aussi et c'est elle en fait qui
m'a amené un jour en entraînement et en
fait j'ai adoré le sport collectif à
l'extérieur avec du contact
la précision quand on arrive à la voir
alors moi c'est mon petit fils qui m'a
emmené au rugby féminin vaut le coup
c'est qu'il me demandait quand il était
tout petit il avait 4 ans à l'époque de
l'emmener s'entraîner et du coup les
entraîneurs à fouras mot pris avec les
mots m'ont entraîné alors je trouve que
l'esprit d'équipé encore plus forte au
basket et un esprit d'équipé morumbi
c'est quelque chose de plus fort c'est
un investissement d'une journée avec les
sea lion on mange ensemble jouent
ensemble
voilà c'est quelque chose que je pouvais
pas y a c'est vrai que le rugby féminin
je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait des
traits très bonnes joueuses comme
trémolières et tout ça est en finale on
voit plus rarement leurs matches et on
en comptera beaucoup parler quoi et
pourtant il ya de très très bonnes
joueuses
les équipes comme des mandragores et
tout ça on ne le voit pas on les voit
jamais ça fait quelques années
maintenant que l'on entend plus parler
je pense qu'il faut que nous fassions
les phares aussi pour nous montrer parce
que je pense que toute fille puisse
trouver son épanouissement et que c'est
plus forcément une question de genre
aujourd'hui voilà télé j'en ai jamais vu
personnellement à part à part celle qui
joue le tournoi des six nations des
kills de france non c'est un peu
machiste les garçons en avant c'est pas
l'image qu'on allait
il ya quelques années de la femme qu'on
a aujourd'hui moi je crois en évolution
justement en changement au changement de
ces valeurs et testé au type au final
puisque ça reste que des stéréotypes et
et j'encourage toute personne a essayé
le rugby parce que filles ou garçons
dans tous les cas c'est un sport dans
lequel on peut s'éclater vont se
retrouver avec des amis où on se
retrouve autour du ballon autour d'un
verre et que ce soit dans la vie
sportive ou personnel il y aura toujours
un apport riches à pratiquer cette
discipline
[Musique]